we'll start off with something new
something new that you've both learned
in the past couple weeks and the
criteria is something that has to be
interesting to you clearly and then it
also should be relevant to the
conversation
so John why don't you start off
um what have I learned I've been reading
uh I've learned a lot I'm trying to
think of something that might be
relevant I don't know how this
conversation is going to go so
preemptive judgments of relevance are
extremely uh tricky If someone knows
relevance it's you
mean
I love wisdom that doesn't mean I'm wise
um
I've been reading uh an essay well first
an essay on Nishida says essay on
intelligibility and it's been very
interesting to me because I'm seeing a
rather profound convergence between Zen
philosophical Notions of intelligibility
in the neoplatonic ones and I'm finding
that
um
I'm finding that a very powerful uh
because that kind of convergence says
something across cultures and time
you're getting that kind of convergence
lends plausibility to this examination
of intelligibility and as you know I do
a lot of work around what is
intelligibility
ETC so I think that will turn out to be
relevant uh to our discussion but I'm
I'm I I'm also really happy to see where
this discussion is going to go I'm
really sort of excited to be here
talking with Donald and I I know he has
an extremely flexible mind so I'm I'm
just uh but I think intelligibility uh
might come up as a relevant topic great
I want to make a note for later you said
that you love wisdom but you're not sure
if you're wise I don't know does the
love of wisdom imply that you're wise
though
in the same way that loving what's good
implies that you're good no no that's
was exactly that was exactly my point my
the fact that I study relevance and I
love it doesn't mean I'm necessarily an
expert at enacting it
um in fact people often go into
psychology to study what they most lack
um and so I may actually be somebody
who's initially very I know within
social circumstances I've generally been
poor at picking up what's relevant and
it's been something that I've been
learning over time very slowly
such as the curse of academics okay Don
well I've been um working on a paper on
relationship of Consciousness to physics
and so I've been thinking a lot about
that we're about to submit it uh this
week and
trying to show how we boot up space-time
and particle physics from a theory of
Consciousness and so one thing just as I
was driving yesterday
um
that I learned just by putting some
pieces together the physicists have this
notion about
um the vacuum and relationship to a
certain mathematical structure is called
permutations and they they relate them
the vacuum to the trivial permutation
and then particle interactions to these
non-trivial permutations called
decorative permutations and and I
realized in our friend yesterday so what
I learned was as I was reviewing the
mathematics of our mathematical
framework of Consciousness I realized
the dynamical aspect of conscious agents
that corresponds to the vacuum and it
corresponds to agents
um whose Dynamics
um is completely transient it they don't
talk to anybody else and they don't even
talk to themselves so they're they're
markovian Dynamics is completely
transient and that that was what
corresponds to what the physicists
called the vacuum State and so but all
of a sudden when I realized that it the
whole thing begins to make sense and so
uh so for me what was a big aha
yesterday was okay I I'm getting
starting with Consciousness trying to
understand particle scattering in
physics as a result of Consciousness and
I understand what the vacuum means that
it actually makes sense in the
mathematical framework we're dealing
with so so I guess it's relevant because
if we end up talking about Consciousness
and space-time and physics and
physicalism it these kinds of Concepts
will be very very relevant
are you trying to study scattering
because you're inspired by nema's work
partly and I'm trying to study
scattering because ultimately
if we want to have a mathematically
precise scientific theory of
Consciousness that's going to be taken
seriously by the scientific World you've
got to make predictions that are
testable
and
a lot of my colleagues are thinking we
need to make predictions at the
Neuroscience level and of course we
eventually do but but but brains are
really complicated and uh particles are
very simple so my my goal is to make
predictions about two gluons in four
gluon out scattering first because not
because that's harder because it's
easier than neuroscience and the
physicists have already given us a way
into that so they they've said if you
want to do particle scattering
um
there are these structures beyond space
time like the amplitohedron and then the
deeper structures the decorated
permutations and so they say if you can
give us a decorative permutation we can
give you a scattering amplitude uh for
for some kind of particle Dynamics and
so what I've been working on is is that
starting with the theory of
Consciousness this dynamical show how
the decorative permutations come out and
from then I can just then use all the
wonderful work by the physicists like
Nema and his collaborators that start
with these decorated permutations and
give you scattering amplitudes the big
goal is to start with Consciousness and
make predictions at colliders that are
testable and hopefully new predictions
that their current models can't make
right I would like to for example
explain why supersymmetry doesn't work
uh based on this dynamics of conscious
agents so so not just
of course we need to get all the stuff
that they've already done and we need to
be able to you know capture their
predictions that they've already tested
but we need to make new predictions as
well so that's why I was really working
on the scattering amplitudes because
one they're a way to empirically test
the theory number two we know this
really well we we have the data we know
what the right answers are and we know
what the outstanding problems are and um
and and and then the fourth thing is I
would rather start there than
Neuroscience because it may seem
counter-intuitive but but the scattering
is going to be much much easier than
making connections with Neuroscience
that are that are absolutely rigorous
and testable to you know 10 decibel
places or something like that
okay so the last broad question and then
I'm going to leave the floor open to you
both to riff off of one another is what
is it that you find impactful about one
another's work and we'll start Dawn with
you toward John and then John you'll
respond and then I'll interject fairly
seldomly
okay yeah well with John what's what's
beautiful is he's a one of those rare
truly Renaissance individuals who who
knows ancient philosophy and modern
philosophy you know modern Neuroscience
uh he knows evolutionary psychology he
knows um the scientific method backwards
and forwards but he also knows mystical
traditions and he knows how to pick and
choose from all of these in an
intelligent way to get a synthesis that
is then I think uh potentially
life-changing for many many people to
get meaning in our lives to understand
our current political situation and so
he's one of those rare individuals who
who really knows this broad variety of
topics he knows how to integrate them
he's not just a dilettante but he
actually knows how to integrate them in
a transformative light and the other
thing I love is is um his absolute
demand for clean precise logical
thinking when you're thinking but then
he's welding in spiritual Traditions to
go into silence as well so and I think
both are absolutely essential for the
full human being and the full human
scientist
thank you Donald that was um
very kind and um
I
that speaks to what I like about you
um right um I think you
I think you and I belong to the school
of what I like to call Big Picture
cognitive science which is not this or
that I mean you do specialist work and I
do specialist work but we we don't think
that's the core of good science that
integrating into a broad framework is
important and Frameworks like you that
try to bridge between uh like you do
like I do as well try to bridge you know
between a lot of the things that have
been vivisected off each from each other
in our society in our current scientific
worldview
um I think you asked big questions I
think you uh you I somebody who talks
about
Consciousness and Ultimate Reality and
yet wants to talk about it in a
scientifically rigorous even
mathematical formalized mathematical way
um you can see why I deeply resonate
with that I may not agree with all of
your particular conclusions uh and
that's to be said I mean do any two
academics uh but the point is
um uh I think Levi can put it this way
and many important ways we're on the
same side of the tracks we think we
should be doing these Broad
uh Integrations that are not facile but
are pertinent precise well-arged for
well-evidenced
um and that they have important
existential sapiential and therefore
spiritual in that sense consequences
that should be respected uh we should
not limit
um the pool from which we're drawing our
analyzes to just sort of current
philosophy or current science but much
more broad cross-cultural across
historical cross-disciplinary
um so I mean
like I say
I'm sure we'll get into disagreement but
I I want to say this up front which is
the ma I often say this and I mean it
and people can see that I mean it and
how I uh how I
how I carry myself in discussions the
manner in which you're doing these
things I think is really really right in
a profound and important way
um and I think you you present it in a
way that's often
um very challenging to people who have
have a much more
I want to be kind here much more
specialized I was going to say blinkered
but a much more specialized
um epistemology and I think that is
really needed now I think all
I'll speak for psychology we both are in
Psychology at least we both have a point
I have one in Psychology and cognitive
science you have one in Psychology and
other things too
um philosophy cognitive science uh but
one of the things that bothers me about
psychology is this emphasis on
Innovation as opposed to integration I
would argue that's one of the things
driving the replication crisis and I
think the resistance to right creating
broad philosophically astute Frameworks
within psychology is something that
needs to be challenged and I see that
you and I are both doing that and I
think that's very very important you
know what let me ask a question so I'll
start this off with the perhaps the most
basic question we say that conscious or
some people say that Consciousness is
fundamental and then there's various
questions like well what is
consciousness
and if one does have to assume
reductionism for something to be
fundamental then does that mean that
conceptually reductionism is more
fundamental than the x that you're
saying is fundamental so anyway what is
fundamental
I'll be happy to start sure sure so I
think that
there's two important and different
concepts going on here one is
um reductionism which has to do with an
assumption about space-time being
fundamental
and with reductionism the idea is that
as you go to smaller and smaller scales
in space-time
you get to more and more fundamental
objects and more and more fundamental
laws
so that's a particular idea and by the
way reductionism is assuming uh um that
space-time itself is fundamental I mean
because it's taking smaller scales of
space as being associated with more and
more fundamental objects and laws
but fundamental for me is a much broader
concept than than say space time
fundamental is a property of scientific
theories so every scientific theory
um has assumptions
no theory in science is free of any
assumptions these assumptions are the
foundation of that scientific theory and
so what's fundamental is this it is is
with respect to a particular Theory what
what does that take as the fundamental
uh concepts for building that theory so
I I think the notion of fundamental is a
theory
relative concept you should ask
um what's fundamental in this particular
scientific theory in Einstein's theory
of gravity space time is fundamental in
uh you know Evolution Financial
selection we have the notion of physical
objects in space-time and things like
genes and competition and replication
those are those are fundamental concepts
in in that theory but you can have uh
different scientific theories with with
different fundamental concepts most of
modern science does take
space-time as fundamental but then
they'll also add other
other Concepts as well to be fundamental
like in evolution you'll also add
organisms and DNA and replication and
and so forth so but and so most
scientific theories also inherit the
assumption that reductionism is is a
good method most of them do um
I'll just I'll turn it over to John but
I'll just say that physicists now are
saying that space-time is not
fundamental like Neymar and others and
that therefore reductionism
um is is doomed not just space-time but
reductionism is is doomed
um but but I'll stop there
so I agree with I think I'm agreeing
with Donald that
um I would want to distinguish uh
reductionism from claims of
fundamentality
um I think productionism is very
problematic
uh it has uh it gets you into certain
performative contradictions if you try
to make an absolute complete
reductionism because it gets you into
saying things like only the bottom level
is real and I know that from this level
up here which isn't real you get all
kinds of performative contradictions
going on there you have measurement
problems uh Wolfgang Smith has brought
this out you know the the ruler can't be
a Quantum thing to measure the Quantum
of things or you get into and I I won't
review that there's a host of problems
where I think reductionism and and a
completely flat ontology aren't uh
justifiable briefly why do you say
performative contradiction and not
contradiction performative contradiction
means that there isn't a contradiction
between propositions there's
contradictions between the activity and
the proposition stated here's one I'm
asleep right now
okay that doesn't make any sense it's a
performative contradiction because the
action
requires the the falsity of the
proposition right so can you explain why
suggesting that there's some ground
that's more real than a higher level is
a performative contradiction
ah what I was saying is if you if you
say that the bottom level is the only
level that's at re with real that is
clearly not the level at which the
science is being done the science is
being done by scientists using gauges
and writing things down and using
computers and using language and making
theories and going to conferences and if
all of that is not real because it's
somehow Epi phenomenal or illusory then
how is it that that level is giving you
epistemic access to the real bottom
level you're saying like it's be like
saying I'm in the middle of a dream and
in that dream I I dreamed that Santa
Claus was real therefore Santa Claus is
real like if if you if the level at
which you're doing the science is
illusory it undermines all the claims
you're making from that level you have
to be able to give it on top on
ontological reality to science if any of
its conclusions are going to be taken to
be real that's beautiful
thank you so that's I and there's a host
of other arguments and I I want to put
reductionism aside for that now
fundamental and I agree with Donald
completely fundamental is a theoretic
um but one thing you can be connoting
not denoting is what you think is the
the ontological referent uh which is
what some people sometimes mean by
fundamental and I I think instead of
using fundamental which is a theoretic
property we might want to use an
ontological property like real and then
you might be asking what is it to say
that something is real or to say that
one thing is more real than another and
I think that is an important question
and I think that question can't be
decided by just looking within any
particular theory for its particular
fundamentals because what we're asking I
think I would argue when we're asking
questions about reality is what what
what makes possible any and all such
intelligibility what makes possible any
possible theory that might turn out to
be true there has to be some aspect
because we take it I think that reality
in some sense corresponds to
our ability to make our claim to find
our claims true or our skills apply
applying or a perspectives present
um Etc so I I'm waving over with that
with my hand because that's a big thorny
knot but I'm trying to pull apart I
think there's reductionism which we put
aside there's fundamentality and I will
I agree with Donald what he just said
about that and but I think we have an
extra theoretic notion which is the
notion of realness which is something
like that which can make you know
various theories true how do they do it
and then the question might be are you a
pluralist or modest about that for
example that might be a starting point
do you think there are many different
realities that make theories true you
could be some kind of relativist in that
way or do you think that there is a
Ultimate Reality in some important
unified fashion Etc so there there's
three different questions we could be
asking reductionism which I I'd largely
put aside what's the fundamental of any
Theory but you might ask what's reality
and you might ask it in saying what is
it that could possibly integrate
non-reductively all these fundamentals
together so that we would have an over
our integrated coherent account
that's those those are the kinds of
moves you can make
did that make sense
sure so don
do you have anything to say in response
I think that
you know the notion of reality is an
extra notion Beyond just what's
fundamental to a particular Theory
that the and this whole area is very
very tricky you know for the very kinds
of performative contradiction reasons
that John just mentioned
very very easy to step on land mines
everywhere here but it seems to me that
that
girdle's in completeness theorem
tells us that in some sense there is no
Theory of Everything
right any formal system that is Rich
enough to model the
axiom's arithmetic is is either
inconsistent or incomplete and we call
it girdles in completeness theorem
because we don't take the inconsistency
thing too seriously so
that means no matter what
scientific theory we have
it's not the final word there'll always
be if the if the theory is Rich enough
to do arithmetic and most scientific
theories are either they wouldn't be
taken seriously so the rich enough to do
arithmetic so they're rich enough to
have a girdle statement that uh that is
outside their scope and yet it's true
um but not provable within that theory
and and no matter how much you add those
new statements to your your scientific
theory they'll always be new statements
that that so that that means that are
there there is no scientific theory of
everything
and the notion of Truth and and and I
think the related notion of reality
that's why I'm bringing this up the
notion of Truth and and the notion of
reality in some sense I think will
forever transcend
scientific theory and of course I'm a
scientist so I'm not saying oh throw up
our hands and yeah there's something
very deep going on here that that that
that that
theories turn out to be empirically
quite valuable right when we're I'm
alive today because of scientific
theories that that led to medicine that
have saved my life so so the you know
the stuff works even though girl tells
me that it that it's um the theory is
Trivial compared to the truths that the
theories uh can't prove right so so
there so the fact that you can't have a
theory of everything
um and you can't ultimately
know that the truth with a capital T and
therefore and this is where John may
want to disagree I don't know therefore
we can't know what what's reality with a
capital R we we can only say these are
the best theories we have so far but we
need to modestly and humbly say
um that's our Theory that's not the
truth and I would be fooled to say that
that's the reality
um so I would but I should probably stop
and let John react I just want to thank
Donald for being I hope I I follow his
example and continually make space for
him as well yeah okay great great so
apologies for me not making space here
for taking some space so with girdles
incompleteness theorem he said that we
may never know truth with the capital T
and then you said that a tote may not
exist however there's the difference
between a total existing and US knowing
the toe and when you said that we don't
know truth with a capital T to me that
truth with a capital t is the same as
the toe that's a statement then I'll get
you to respond to that and then second
is that there are certain assumptions in
girdle's theorem so for instance that
the laws would have to be based in first
order logic or that the laws are
consistent because consistency is
actually an implicit requirement and
it'd be strange to say that the world is
inconsistent though there are some
people who I'm sure on the more Mystic
end who may say that reality is a
contradiction paradoxes are at the
bottom and the top and there's no bottom
and top but there is
well those are some ways of getting
around it and that's why when I hear
people like myself maybe even two years
ago would say girdles incompleteness
theorem says there is no toe uh that's a
bit dubious to me so I want to hear what
are your responses to that and then John
so please then comment
I like I'd like to hear Donald's
response to that first
right well so I I would say your point
is about taking Kurt the way I would
think about it is to say
the fact that we can't have a theory of
everything doesn't mean that there isn't
a truth out there
a real a real true reality
and from spiritual traditions we learn
that that perhaps um that's what you are
you're not divorced from that reality
you are that reality and and you can't
know that reality through intellectual
and conceptual knowing but you can know
it firsthand by being that reality and
so and so so there could be this notion
of truth and reality
uh that transcends the notion of a
theory of everything see a theory of
everything starts off with a finite set
of Concepts and and and says here's how
far I can go with this set of Concepts
um and so my my argument would be you
know along the lines of girdles kind of
argument that if you start with any
finite axiomatization or any finite set
of Concepts you can come up with an
infinite number of theorems absolutely
you can come up with an infinite number
of theorems but there will be
probability zero compared to all the
truths that that that that are out there
um and so that's why I would I mean but
again there's this meta notion that John
was bringing up so I'm I'm here I am
talking about Truth uh using words
um and but but saying the concepts
themselves have very limited meaning the
the only
Escape out of it is for me is is this
issue that
um the spiritual Traditions bring up
which is um
you can't talk about the truth but you
are it your very being is it and and so
when you when you speak that being
itself is projecting down into a finite
set of Concepts to talk with with other
avatars of the being
um but and and so I think that there's a
way not to be self-refuting
um in that but I again I would love to
have John contradict me I don't know if
I'm going to contradict you or not
um
yeah I I I
think the go to argument still has value
with respect to formal systems
um whether or not theories are formal
systems I think it's a genuine
philosophical question
um I think you know we clearly had
theories before there was math
um and their Bonafide theories Plato has
a theory of the psyche and whether or
not you could call that a formal system
um I think is is questionable
um and yet there was a lot of I would
say there's a lot of Truth in Plato's uh
Theory it turned out to be you know it's
been got quite a bit of empirical
confirmation uh recently so
um so I'm a little bit hesitant about
that but I take your point to be correct
uh and Donald in fact I take it very
deeply and I actually think this is a
platonic point and this is something
that comes out in plania's work as well
I take one of the ways in which we
determine that something's real is
precisely it it's inexhaustibleness
um it's but it's not cacophonous and
exhaustibility and this is the thing
this is what I think Plato meant by the
good we get it's in it everything is an
inexhaustible fount of intelligibility
we can learn more and more so I do not
think there is a limited number of
truths about anything I think the number
of true even the number of true
descriptions of this very plain Stone
um is indefinitely large it's
inexhaustible
um Etc and this is what I talk about
multi-spectuality and things like that
so I don't think of
um I don't think I'm disagreeing with
you because I think that being an
inexhaustible fount of intelligibility
is precisely one of the ways in which we
determine that something is real uh and
um and I think that for phenomenological
reasons and for uh for cognitive reasons
I also think that
um truth is a retrospective notion
um like real it's a comparative notion
um so when I say something's real or
something's an illusion I'm always
making a comparison when I say this is
true
the entire history of science shows that
to be the case again and again and again
and I think that's the notion I think
the notion of Truth we're using is a
retrospective comparative notion
um I don't think that that means it's an
illusion I think we should give up the
Cartesian notion that truth points to
some complete absolute formalized grasp
of something and that the Criterion of
knowledge is certainty uh and because
we've tried that and it collapses it
certainly doesn't underwrite science uh
because you know it's it's very
plausibly the case that many of our
current best theories will turn out to
be rejected in the future right this is
Lawton's uh you know pessimistic
argument I think it has to be taken very
seriously now the last thing that Donald
said and what I think with him is
convergent with everything I just said
sends Shivers up my spine because you
know I've been I've been arguing that
there are kinds of knowing other than
propositional inferential there's
procedural there's spectival and there's
participatory which is knowing by being
and I agree that many of these mystical
Traditions say you know the the way to
come in most contact with reality is not
through your conceptual propositional
knowing but it's through your
perspectival and all ultimately your
participatory knowing and I agree that
that that
is always the case no no give me a
moment here what I mean by that is
something like what Marla Ponte or or 40
Cox I would say right is
even my propositional things are
ultimately dependent on skills my skills
are dependent on perspectives my
perspectives are always dependent on
participatory identity and so the
spiritual Traditions are not they're
just explicating something that is
always the case they're not proposing
something that's over there that only
only the great gifted ones can realize
um I mean that's part of I think what's
a little bit wrong with the way some of
these spiritual Traditions have been
taken up right but I think what the
spiritual Traditions are pointing to is
exactly that fact that that there's a
there's an asymmetric dependence
relation the propositional is dependent
on the procedural the procedural is
dependent on the perspectival and the
perspectival is dependent on the
participatory and so for me I try to
understand realness in terms of what
best integrates those four together
um when we're making claims of about how
things are
well very good very very good
I agree I like the idea that the truth
is related to some kind of inexhaustible
uh Arena that we're going to keep keep
learning and and
also in the case of scientific theories
and the relationship to that notion of
Truth
for me what's impressive about a
scientific theory is when it predicts
its own demise uh yes sorry for
interrupting sorry
yeah that that's for for me A scientific
theory is one that that when you really
understand the theory it tells you the
limits of its Concepts and it tells you
where it stops and it tells you that at
this point you will need uh not just a
tweak you will need a new framework
you will need a new set of foundational
Concepts
and but the the nice thing about science
in this regard is that the constraint is
whatever new framework that you if this
current theory is is one that we take
seriously like like Einstein's theory of
gravity or Quantum filtering right and
it tells you its limits or evolution by
natural selection and this theory that
we say okay right now this is one of the
best theories Humanity has ever had
and and we look for its limits
when we get the new deeper Theory with
new conceptual framework perhaps
we don't just get pick that willy-nilly
and however we want there is a
constraint our old theories can't tell
us what's beyond they can tell us that
there's something Beyond but they can't
tell us what is beyond but they can veto
our bad ideas so what we have to do is
build our new framework with new
Concepts and then we need to show
that there is some kind of projection a
simplified sub-model of our new more
General model gives us back evolution by
natural selection or it gives us back
Quantum field Theory and space time
that's that's the constraint if we can't
do that or when we project it back we
get something that includes Evolution
and a little bit more for example it
could be an augmented theory of
evolution it doesn't be exactly but it
better not lose anything that we know
and love from evolutionary theory or
better tell us in convincing ways why we
were mistaken about that aspect of it
right so so that's the constraint so so
I I see truth in in
and the real as uh you know
you know these absolute things that
there are Concepts will never they will
scratch the surface but they will never
probe the depths
and what science is and and of course
even you know
pre-scientific theories like like
Plato's for example as you mentioned
what these theories are doing is using
Concepts to to explore yes truth and and
there with with science what we get
that's new
is
precise mathematical precise statements
of the limit of the theory and and what
a wonderful
[Music]
um cure for dogmatism because when your
own Theory tells you its limits if you
buy the theory you have to buy the
limits and so you have to buy that you
don't have the final answer and that's
that's really uh so that's the cure for
dogmatism so so theories that I love a
theory where the theory itself is humble
enough to tell you where it stops and
but but also smart enough to be able to
veto any bad ideas you have for what's
next
on that note where do you both see your
own theories indicating their limits
well first of all I want to reply to
what Donald said because I think he just
put his finger on something that I've
been arguing and I think there's a point
of convergence here
we put a lot of emphasis on coherence
and other features for our understanding
of rationality but I think this capacity
to do what Donald has just argued which
is a genuine capacity to afford
principled self-correction vetoing
things out and then pointing Beyond
um I think this is a Hallmark of
rationality that is not emphasized
enough and this is I often tell my
students even at a heuristic level if
you want to assess somebody's
rationality look how much they are
willing to criticize their own work at
some point or correct their previous
work I don't expect it in like in in the
moment they're talking because that's
but like can they look at something they
did a year or two ago and go oh here's
all the mistakes in there right
um and that I think is really really
important now
um
I I think
I think what I would say is that and
then I'll
um I'll ask you to re-ask your question
Kurt if if you want to change it modify
but for me therefore
um truth is like Notions like
orientation and navigation
um you're properly oriented and the
orientation rules a lot of things out
we're not going that way we're not going
that way we're not going there and then
navigation is constantly telling you how
you have to adjust and reformulate how
you're doing and you might find from the
navigation that you need to reorient
right that's up and that's always a
possibility but that's not the same as
wandering around willy-nilly right
there's a there's a very big difference
and so that's what I meant when I think
truth is always retrospective you can
always look back and say hey look at how
far we have rely we are closer we we may
have to change our Direction but we've
made genuine on you know I'm using the
spatial metaphor here progress and so
that's what I think is really crucial
um I I
this may sound like I I I I'm splitting
a hair
but I want to argue that I'm not because
this notion of Truth as orientational
and navigational rather than as a
completed grasp of something I think is
really really important right now and I
think we really have to pause and and
and and for example let me just say one
thing and then I'll shut up unless you
let you re-ask your your question but I
just wanted to pick up on this point
because Donald was saying something
about theories and I think it directly
also corresponds to how we should
understand rationality
um and and so
if what he said is true and I agree it
is and what I'm saying is true that
means that there are a lot of and this
is ties back again to what the spiritual
Traditions can hold out for us there are
a lot of truths that are not accessible
to US unless we're willing to undergo
significant transformation
right once you give up oh no I can just
grasp this thing with this Universal
method leibniz's calculus once you give
that up and you say no no no there's
going to be this constantly going on
that the demand like the the
presupposition that you can sort of
Remain epistemically the grammar of your
uh of your epistemic Machinery can
remain unaltered in order to get access
to truth I think that is uh deeply
challenged if not outright falsified but
that presupposition of a universal
method is that does not require personal
transformation is fundamental to the
whole Cartesian framework and see I
think the spiritual Traditions are there
reminding us that no no your methods can
do a lot but there's a lot of truths
that are only disclosable to you after
you go through profound self-correction
which is profound self-transcendence
which is profound transformation I just
wanted to make that point very clear you
just watched a clip from the theories of
everything channel for the full video
and all its magnificence then click here
and if you'd like to see more then
subscribe enjoy